the reddit discussion forum that we run
is now home to around 2,300 of our
viewers and listeners there it is
growing and growing another record month
already days before the end of the month
is even here really great discussion
going on we've brought on a couple of
moderators to ensure that blatant
trolling and personal attacks aren't out
of control they're doing an excellent
job let's take a look at some of the
popular discussions from the last week
on reddit a very detailed response to my
story about concerns over identity
politics being prevalent at the Women's
March and a really thoughtful response
generating a lot of discussion another
thread from reddit I know exactly what
Donald said to Milania a user I guess
hypothesizing about what Donald Trump
said to Melania Trump in that now viral
clip that we played earlier this week
also from our reddit discussion forum a
viewer who had their face in my
commitment to ethical and responsible
journalism shaken by my interview of alt
right white nationalist leader Richard
Spencer we'll deal with that more a
little bit later in the show also from
reddit Spencer is crazy as hell people
coming away with the perception that
Richard Spencer is out of his mind as a
result of the interview and also from
our read a discussion forum Trump's
press secretary Sean Spicer has an odd
long-running feud with dippin dots I did
not know about this until I saw it on
our reddit discuss discussion forum and
that is indeed true and lastly from our
reddit discussion forum thanks to trump
scientists are planning to run for
office a very very interesting article
from the Atlantic which I encourage you
to check out so join participate suggest
stories suggest guests to be interviewed
and you can subscribe of course at david
pakman.com slash read it costs nothing
join the community be a part of it